imaginez être chez vous puis tout à coup
pendant la nuit
vous entendez ceux ci se crise et celui
de nathalie poirier victime de braquage
à son domicile dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche un cri strident qui a effrayé
sa voisine j'étais sous le choc j'ai vu
deux hommes habillés en noir avec des
capuchons dans ma phase les deux tout de
suite ont sauté sur moi ils vont être
anglais jouaient à penser que quelqu'un
se faisait violer j'ai eu très peur mais
après ce que je me suis peut-être
c'était juste un rêve
son récit ne s'arrête pas là une fois à
l'intérieur les malfaiteurs à la
recherche d'argent ont arraché les
portes de sa garde-robe
ils sont partis avec combien final une
40 dollars nathalie poirier se montre
tout de même fier d'elle 1 - avant
l'incident elle avait fait installer
chez elle une caméra de surveillance qui
a presque tout capté une pratique qui
serait en hausse selon cette entreprise
de sécurité résidentielle 2016 ont
installé environ 10 12 caméras
extérieures
demain 17 ans passés à 125 et maintenant
cet été à ce jour on est rendu à 390 fut
tellement ça se multiplie à hudson et
dans toute la mrc de vaudreuil soulanges
il n'y a pratiquement pas eu de vol
qualifié l'an dernier selon le dernier
rapport annuel de la sûreté du québec
la division des crimes majeurs poursuit
son enquête sur ce qui est arrivé à
nathalie poirier afin de retrouver les
suspects mais pourrait elle se remettre
du choc sera non non je vais pas tout
seul je vais pas été de celle jugée
vraiment marre tout seul je sais pas
comment je vais faire ça je sais pas
comment je vais m'en sortir au lien or
au moins j'ai le soutien de ma famille
et mes amis ici militants françois radio
canada oddsson